we have a throne in here from Ronnie's
roast when you see the dildo throne
there are 69 dildos on that throne we
don't know what to do with it we know
there are I got a whole tutorial on the
throne yesterday and well it was me tell
people 69 in other words that's what I'm
going with you 69 69 dildos but really
200 everything has to be done on a
budget right we're now dildo
manufacturer we've manufactured over 200
dildos for the chair that Ronnie sat on
and it only cost us 75 it's a miracle
yeah an artist worked on this throne we
had an artist what artist they said then
artists went over those yeah Vincent van
Gogh dad
vanes and all kinds of Vincent van Gogh
now one of his balls
[Laughter]